every played
still this little check over here you
have to keep an eye open for
the evaluation bar is all the way in fit
its favor
and after the trade of Rogue so what are
we going to see if a vid at night takes
people no D5
keeps finding tricks so it does Yan he
keeps finding moves that just get the
game
rolling a little bit further but the
problem is now
after the king moves to me too this
queen has nowhere to go that is the end
vidit goes through to the next round
amazing stuff there brilliant play by
video and Yan been very gracious in in
defeat there but our vid it deserves
that one doesn't he Ivanka
you could just see the smile on
Veteran's face
the tension the relief of the qualifying
into the